awesome alright I'm really really
excited to be here today with you all
look yes my name is Padma so a quick
introduction I'm the head of product and
design at seven West media which is
based over in Australia and as mentioned
yes I'm from Perth and we do have very
adorable quokka animals so that's kind
of me that's traveled over here for the
first time ever in Europe and I'm super
super excited to be here it's it's
amazing and it's quite an experience so
I bring over with me a little bit of
Aussie slang so I suppose this I have
been told that my accent is quite strong
so I hope you can all understand me but
we do like to have a few idioms where we
connect and concatenate some words
together and one of the words that I
want to run through with you all today
is hard Yakka now actually who's heard
of the term hard Yakka before okay we've
got a few hands yeah cool hey in the
back there
now hijack our is basically all the
meaning of it is basically hard work and
it comes from rural slang essentially um
so in the country there's wood which is
referred to as yucca and hide yucca is
that meaning of hard work and work ethic
and this term reminds me of my grandad
look how cute he is
he's so adorable that's a really big
picture but he's one of the most
hard-working people that I know and he's
got an amazing work ethic and he's also
one of those people who just has sage
advice for any scenario and he's one of
my greatest role models so he'll say
things like work hard and be good to
your mother
hmm listen before you speak and never
say gone up because if you gone up you
haven't done it yet and he's taught me a
lot about work ethic and having just
I suppose that determination to really
apply apply myself and to work hard no
matter no matter what the circumstance
and just set goals and go for it so he's
really taught me a lot about resilience
and diligence and determination of
course but this transition of work ethic
and hard Yakka in our industry has been
something that I've been trying to
adjust to for this 15 years I've been
here in working in the web and I suppose
that concept of it it's tricky because
well the state of our industry is
something that requires a lot of mental
willpower and there's something that is
not quite the same about it like other
industries would have in a traditional
sense so I suppose I just wanted to ask
you all a few questions today
because this is something that's been
swirling around in my mind for a little
bit and it's the observation of I
suppose what's become normal in our
industry constant learning so what I
mean by this is well as you all know in
our industry we're always learning
something new so suppose here's a simple
question for you all who's learned
something new this week last week last
month daily if it's continually
continuous and constant learning and
it's also a continuous change another
question for you all who's doing the
exact same workflow as what they did two
years ago
one year ago one month ago okay okay
does it that right also community well
no connectivity I've done forward sorry
um who hops on their laptops or their
machines after work or on the weekends
well that's a lot of hands yep me too me
too
and who goes out
and hangs out with the community a fair
bit who runs or volunteers or attends
meetups all the time
contributions who's who's contributed to
open-source software in this last week
this month this year again and the last
see that I wanted to bring in and talk
about it in the state about industry is
also creativity and in that sense of how
many of you have a side project going on
or a working on a side project have
worked on the side projects thinking
about working on a side project yeah
that's that's a lot happening right that
some we're doing all of this stuff
probably on top of full-time work or
full-time study and you know that's
that's a lot of hours that we're putting
into this world so then I kind of got to
thinking about you know what is it that
we value and normalize as good strong
work ethic you know in history
what's the hard Yakka here and really
you know it's it's what we value right
as human beings and as professionals and
we hear kind of hear these kind of
phrases that swirl around and humble
brags that happen
and these might sound familiar you know
there's such a gonna dev it's super fast
and then we might do the whole I worked
nine hours today well I worked ten hours
today and I worked 24 and there's like
this kind of humblebrag that's happening
and you know it's this this kind of
sense of well that is what we consider
maybe working harder but then we've also
got this kind of world surrounding us as
well which is you know blog posts and
contributing and working on side
projects and mentoring and all these
other things that we do to kind of keep
progressing our career forward and then
we kind of have this really hard workman
type mentality but we you know we do all
these things of well it's so much to do
and I'm so busy and these are the the
general normal conversation
that we have and to me I kind of kind of
worried because what we're saying to not
only ourselves but to the people that
are looking up to us or that we speak to
day to day the things that we're
praising each other about our same
things like these so I suppose more
translations that somehow high
performance is related to shipping
things quickly regardless of quality
tech debt maintainability we're saying
hey yes smash it out like let's go get
all the things done all that clocking
hours becomes this brat a badge of pride
that's somehow related to productivity
because we're doing so much all the time
and we're always busy you know is that a
good thing and doing all of these things
somehow is expected of us to get ahead
in this industry if you're not doing all
of those things that I was listing out
before with the state of our industry
somehow you know how are we performing
the best that we can all already meeting
our potential and the other thing I'm
reading into it
is if we're always busy and needed then
this relates to somehow the I'm value
board conversation so I see a few nods
out there and this is kind of my
reaction like what is happening to our
industry
it doesn't quite sound right kind of
like beasts like a little yeah I love it
so I suppose one we're kind of looking
at good old Google leveling up you know
if we want to level up as developer or a
human being then all of a sudden we have
to go well what what are the steps that
we need to take to do that and all the
things that are expected of us there and
I came across this tweet from Eric
Elliott a little while ago and it really
got me thinking and it's it's one of
those reflective pieces right so I think
of the most extraordinary developer
you've ever worked with they're more the
traits and qualities that they have and
the results of this survey he wrote a
great blog post about it so feel free to
go
go forth and check it out
he came out with these top five
qualities communicative efficient
collaborative committed honest cool top
five traits problem-solve our skilled
mentor teacher excellent learner
passionate yeah cool
not bad I mean these are things that I
would personally expect us any kind of
working professional to have these kind
of skills and traits but you know kind
of add to this we'll see lots of
mindmaps around about the state of the
web and wow just keeps going and you
know that's from front end to back end
it helps to you know to sitting this
full-stack world and it's it's so full
on and we're just learning all these
things constantly and there's all these
expectations I notice you know
everything and then we're just it's
tiring
you know um do we do we accept this do
we accept that this is a healthy
environment that we want people to come
into our industry and go hey yeah
working 10 hours to 15 hours to getting
no sleep and being busy all the time
it's cool yeah I don't know I don't know
with this state of the world I feel like
it's my wonder we're exhausted and it's
no wonder we're seen people talk about I
suppose the signs and inks and symptoms
of burnout it's I find that really
concerning because there's some really
telling for talented people that are
kind of hitting hitting this stage and
they're not able to recover and they're
leaving the industry or changing the
industry or taking these massive breaks
and when we're thinking about it unit um
a physical sense it's actually a thing
called OTS turns out it's a symptom
overtraining syndrome is something that
is used to describe athletes who have
completely trained themselves to the
state of or over train themselves to the
state of mental or physical exhaustion
and this is this is mega this is
something that is a you know an
imbalance of this simple equation which
is that training should be the result of
workout
and recovery but when a athlete is
diagnosed with OTS they're often out for
four to six months now I've broken a few
limbs in my time and that really only
puts me out for eight you know or six to
eight weeks so this is this is massive
and if we translate this into how this
could work with the mind
we're burnt out from just mental
exhaustion of having to keep up with our
industry and the state of how things are
then our energy is just going to be
pretty low and it's it's pretty hard to
recover back from zero when you know
when we get towards our energy but
actually who plays mortal combat or who
has played Mortal Kombat yep
I think that that is the analogy that
I'm thinking of you know like when your
power bar just goes low and you're at
this stage of well you could lose this
game boom but really with that is when
you've got full energy you can actually
you can do so much more you can be
creative and energetic and you know just
be really inspired but when you're when
you're low on energy you start to have
you know have these uncharacteristic
things happen to yourself like you start
forgetting things
you start having trouble with
communicational you know you start just
being overwhelmed or it's just it gets
too much sometimes and this is something
that I've experienced at at one point in
my time over that 15 years there was a
point where I was working so much and
not getting much sleep and what I
decided to do was make a change of
reducing from full-time hours to three
and a half days a week what that meant
was that two people came on board
full-time to replace at one and a half
days and I wasn't working I feel like
that wasn't right maybe sorry zero
that's not a good thing when we're
thinking about energy so how do we go
about what are the ways that we can move
towards recharging this energy bar
let's not maybe get to that zero point
let's see how we might be able to
restock our pantries and actually these
pantries a word that's used here yeah I
could cupboard with food yeah
maybe I taste like pantries like a
cupboard that would exist in your
kitchen that you would actually store
things like canned food skin and yeah
yeah okay okay so look when that's empty
and you're going to reach in for more
food and nothing's there because you
haven't been restocking it well that's
kind of the same thing with our energy
stores and ways that we can recharge Oh
actually pretty achievable they're all
pretty doorbal and I'll run you through
a few of these methods like taking
regular breaks removing the noise
getting quality sleep not working long
hours and working on things that are
meaningful to you so let's unpack these
a bit further because I think that
they're really important and there's
some really I suppose there's some tools
out there that we can use to really help
us along with this process so taking
regular breaks yeah it sounds simple but
it takes a lot of discipline it actually
takes a lot of willpower to do this and
when you're super super busy all the
time or if there's a culture that or
within your workplace that taken breaks
equals laziness and slacking off maybe
that you know maybe that makes it even
more of a struggle to actually start
doing that so who does actually take
regular breaks that's wonderful that's
really great because you know breaks
breaks can actually there's the sciences
for this there's a lot of studies which
breaks can replenish their psychological
costs associated with working hard
improving work performance and boosting
energy what they're actually helping do
is you're go
your PFC your prefrontal cortex that's
the thinking part of your brain that's
the part that does takes on you know all
of the the logic and the concentration
and executive functions kick you're
focused so that's that's doing a lot so
that's the part that you're actually
using to solve a lot of the problems in
your day to day and because it's doing
so much I feel like doggo should get a
break right I let's recharge so how can
we take in a pretty effective break
scheduled them at right times know when
you're really productive and I suppose
one of them saying that is is fairly
easy but actually knowing when you're
really productive and what methods you
might take to go okay well I'm going to
go in a sprint mode here and then take a
rest here is actually it's different and
individual to how you know we all work
individually as well so that is
something to I know a lot of people
raise their hands but that's something
that you know it's a little bit of
tweaking required so that we might
recharge that that chance of that
overload that we're feeling taking a
pretty effective break it's about
leaving your desk
leaving your workstation giving you a
nice arrest standing up and stretching
drinking water actually taking yourself
out of that environment leaving and then
recharging come back I can't begin to
tell you how many times I've walked away
from my desk and was able to come back
after trying to figure out something for
ages coming back and it was a stinking
semicolon or something ridiculous like
that sorry that's all it took and it
took me a little while to break out at
this because I had this hard Yakka
mentality I just wanted to keep going at
it and taking a break I met that maybe I
am slacking off maybe you know I just
need to push through but that push
through was really detrimental to me so
the tools I used towards this was using
my calendar actually blanking out times
of when I was going to design in those
breaks
was really important because then I was
taking control of that car don't taking
control of that space something like
it's like what reminders of standing up
you can who use a slack yeah you know we
like cool about 50-percent setting up a
slack bot or whatever tool you might be
using internally there to have little
notifications to remind yourself to
stand up and stretch every now and then
it's really really excellent and all
this are I had that designed in for my
team I was working with and while doing
that twice a day and we use that as an
activity to get away from our desks and
just muster in the middle and take a
little stretch break there's only five
minutes twice a day and it just meant
they're all able to have that break um
who's heard of tiny care bot on Twitter
yeah a few hands there it's really
adorable I would suggest if you aren't
on Twitter hop along and follow it along
because that's just like really simple
little gems that really just just give
you a little boost so let's move on to
the next part of topping up the energy
bar removing noise now when we think of
working or in agile development in any
sense we want to remove all that noise
and have this really you know clear
focus on what we're working on so that
we're not distracted by everything else
that's going on and not thinking about
the backlog we basically ensuring that
what we're working on is the important
thing that we're working on we're
supposed to be focused on right there
and then and we can give it our hundred
percent sorry what we want to do is
remove the noise so that we're not doing
a situation where when everything's
important nothing is important scenario
and trying to multitasking you know
splitting our focus across a few things
so how much we want to reduce unwanted
noise same kind of agile methodologies
having calendar calendar hygiene and
checking in on that regularly and the
calendar is something that is it's such
a strong tool that you can use in your
day-to-day by taking control of it you
can blank out these
these areas in your day that you might
be able to go to I can focus but an hour
block here on this particular task or I
can blend how this whole day to just
play or learn or whatever that might be
and it means that you can kind of
continuously look at it and take out
things that might not be relevant
anymore maybe you don't need to go to
six meetups this week maybe you could
just choose one that you really want to
focus on writing things down and getting
them out of your head it's I highly
recommend it because when it's all
swirling around up here it's just noise
so writing down the things that you want
to achieve and what you want to do and
then going through and grooming those
goals definitely definitely a winner
it's um it's something that really helps
with that focus piece Do Not Disturb
modes are another massive one if you're
going to go into a sprint a sprit being
you know so if you wanted to do a
20-minute session of just focus and then
taking were those notifications as well
during those times or notifications when
you're out of hours and after work
we'd probably don't need to be pinged at
all these times and most importantly
probably saying though is a tricky one
to do but that that is it's all about
taking control of our lives and taking
control of the time that we're spending
on what we're doing day to day because
this is temptation to just take on a lot
all the time but it's unnecessary so I
suggest I've suggested calendar a few
times and taking control of that
headspace are peas are really good at
for meditation and taking that bringing
in mindfulness into the approach and
that is something that you can
essentially use to reduce the noise
that's going along going on in there but
it's a you know it's a great tool if
that's where you'd like to head to
there's also another slack bot called
stop breath and think which is pretty
good as well and brings up little
reminders for you and I don't know if
has anyone used the momentum plug-in
kind of looks like this it got a couple
of hands
it's a great little Chrome and Firefox
plug-in that you can install and it just
gives you a focus mode so you can just
focus on one task at a time and then you
have your other little goals that you
have set up as a list on the side and
yeah it just gives you that chance to
just go okay I'm just going to hone in
on one thing and one thing only how
great and that was the slack I was
talking about okay on to a third way of
recharging your energy bar
getting sleep what does a life look like
without healthy sleep lack of
concentration tiredness inability to
make decisions memory loss lower
tolerance it's it's not great it's not
great and I did actually go through a
time where I was getting about four
hours of sleep a night for about three
years running oh I was able to persevere
and that hard Yakka mentality really
pushed me through it but it really it
really got me to a point where I was not
starting to like what I was doing
anymore it was possibly just a bit much
I just I just did not think that I could
sustain this and when we're thinking
back to OTS I was I was getting pretty
tired and but came across this this
quote our thought it was pretty apt if
you routinely lose sleep or choose to
sleep less than needed the sleep loss
adds up the totals sleep lost is called
your sleep debt AJ if you lose two hours
of sleep a night you'll have a sleep
debt or 14 hours after a week and turns
out sleep debt is not something that can
be paid off by a naps either this is you
know it's a fundamental of actually
being able to have a good night's sleep
and be rested enough to be able to
tackle the following day there's so many
resources out there about going okay
well how do we get a good night's sleep
and actually be rested and well
recovered and energized up and look just
a few just a few things that can
get you started along the way if you're
having trouble sleeping at all avoiding
looking at a device an hour before
bedtime schedule in consistent bedtimes
use that calendar avoid alcohol and
caffeine five to six hours before bed
sometimes that's hard especially when
the after parties are so good and
exercising during the day these are just
really simple things and simple steps
that you can take towards that and it's
it's that first step that is the one
that really takes you towards putting
and prioritizing your wellness first
there so quickly just run you through
yet try these tools there's yeah having
the recurring reminder in your app or
your calendar there's sleep cycle apps
and there's sleep watch app as well
which actually want to choose the
passions of your sleep patterns and then
it wakes you up nicely in a window
that's not within your REM and I've got
two more things to go through don't work
long hours easy to say little trickier
to do but super important there's this
term that happens I suppose in our
industry and actually a lot of
industries called presenteeism and this
is the practice of being present in
one's place of work for more hours than
is required especially as a manifest
manifestation of insecurity about one's
job it's not it's not great it's not
great and when we have the culture of
remember I was saying when you know yet
yeah I suppose here there the praise
about our while I watched 10 hours and I
worked 20 hours and hey good on you
great but did they actually get much
done during that time was that really
productive and were they able to recover
from that so this kind of plant thus
narrow of what it would look like if
we're you know we were to happen to
leave on time well you would leave work
on time
look maybe who knows improvement on time
management and communication because if
you if you are leaving at the time you
are supposed to be leaving perhaps
people might be more prepared to catch
you before you go maybe they might be
more organized to say okay well I really
need you for XYZ can we catch up in the
window where you're available and you
might then become a better communicator
of saying well I'm not going to be
available from this time onwards maybe
catch me in a window that I'm available
again taking control of that calendar
again and I mean I mean it sounds pretty
awful but you'll get time to do the
things that you really like to enjoy or
enjoy doing or that are important to you
wouldn't that be a base so here's the
here are the methods I'll suggest is
getting started with that because it can
be a bit difficult especially if there's
a culture within your workplace where
people are staying back or they are
online all the time because that's the
state of our industry right so maybe
just start by booking in a few after
work appointments whether that's a
coffee and a cake with someone whether
that's a you know a walking catch up
with someone else but having a regular
routine maybe something like a fitness
group or climbing or you know whatever
activity you might not want to take on
that you're doing with someone else
means that you have you know that
responsibility buddy you can go out and
do it together
and so committing to let to leaving on
time is it's really something that's
going to take a lot of discipline and
working in that habit might be Oh a
little tricky at first but then you
start to be okay with it and here's
here's a really important one if you are
working a lot of open source projects
ask your boss and create that culture
within that environment that you're
working in for these contributions to be
happening during work hours I think this
is professional development I think this
is the way as an employee or someone
working in the industry you're growing
your skill
in that way and that training should be
endorsed and encouraged within work
hours in some way shape or form so you
know that and also if you're going to a
lot of meetups
that's also training as well maybe try
and balance that out with okay well if
I'm going to a meet-up on one night hey
can I come in later the next day because
that was learning time and just taking
control of that a bit more so that you
might be under spend time on things that
matter and the hard Yakka cipher really
comes in to knowing and understanding
that your time is precious and really
that's our most valuable commodity so
shouldn't we be dedicating that to
things that bring us joy or making us
more US you know what about spending
time with family and friends what about
prioritizing your interests and hobbies
learning and discovery and playing
travel exploration we're you know we're
all very unique human beings that are
inspired by different things so why not
embrace that and something that might
help towards that so that you might have
some more energy to contribute to it is
starting to journal getting things out
of your head and reflecting on it means
that you might have that chance to
actually see it laid out rather just
swelling around your mind feel free to
get a Pinterest or happiness board up
and running I mean it's usually poor
give you those reminders constantly and
deliberately book in time for play I can
taking ownership of your calendar so I
say burn bright in your own way and the
energize people can do even more and we
should take care of ourselves
and take care of each other and what my
granddad would say it's highjacker is
good but don't be dingo